[Musique]
oh
je suis heureux quand je suis issue
c'est sûr que notre environnement
beaucoup il peint depuis plus de 70 ans
inlassablement avec passion et constance
et avec l'idée d'innover sans jamais se
répéter
chasse est de montrer ce côté un peu ma
che ce côté un peu féerique
il peint des paysages de sa région les
forêts les lacs et les rivières de la
côte-nord et surtout le majestueux fjord
du saguenay le sport quand je serai prêt
à faire un choix d'hommes cherchent pas
il a développé sa technique
d'application des couleurs avec une
spatule large sur des panneaux de bois
recomposée et chaignot tournage et c'est
un peu dambre des gestes précis répéter
un million de fois lui permettent de
faire émerger des formes et des couleurs
de manière très personnelle
c'est la magie de recherche prendre de
chance
[Musique]
élevé sur une ferme de cinquante de
chicoutimi renée gagnon a eu la chance
de côtoyer très tôt des peintres
importants qui vont devenir ces modèles
marc aurèle fortin
quand on était sur la ferme et des
peines ou pas de la vieille match dont
on avait un petit étang où les canards
se promenait marcorelle m'a bien en toi
et puis je veux que j'allais m'asseoir à
côté de lui et puis regardez pain que je
le trouvais beaucoup que j'le trouve
intelligent et puis je me disais un jour
j'aimerais commune
[Musique]
rené richard était aussi un modèle qui
est aussi un modèle ozias leduc a été un
modèle le frère de mama a été un des
plus grands marchands de tableaux du
pays on a connu pas mal partis quand on
était enfant il a était copains de jean
paul riopelle et de stanley cosgrove
avec qui il a organisé de nombreuses
parties pêche
mais dans son cas la reconnaissance est
venue assez tardivement vers l'âge de 50
ans shot show se tait pour panne chaque
jour sur ta peau la recherche
chaque jour c'est un peu mon éducation
comment je vais ranger 4 face aux jeunes
adultes
il occupe divers emplois pour faire
vivre ses cinq enfants avant de tout
abandonner pour se consacrer à sa
peinture
pendant des années il vit en ermite en
forêt pour peindre et tenté de se
constituer une signature est une oeuvre
ma plaquette dans ma famille parce que
j'étais à moitié russe a le moins bien
c'est serov il se fait remarquer à
l'étranger d'abord à paris puis en asie
renée gagnon sait s'entourer de
personnes connues influentes qui
l'aideront à se bâtir une réputation et
à obtenir un bon prix pour ses tableaux
plus tard il reçoit des distinctions
comme la médaille de l'assemblée
nationale et des invitations pour
exposer dans quelques grandes villes
canadiennes
mais il reste encore aujourd'hui plus
connue en malaisie que chez lui pendant
trois ou quatre ans je fait grande
tournée asiatique
alors il ya eu plus d'exposition
d'étrangers plus exposition à paris que
j'ai eu à montréal par exemple on lui
reprochait d'être trop contemporain trop
abstrait pour les peintres figuratifs
puis à la fois trop réaliste pour les
abstraits c'est un punk quand même
réussi à faire sa place auprès des
collectionneurs aguerris et à l'étranger
souhaité peu fait au canada par les
autres artistes de cette génération là
à 91 ans renée gagnon semble mener une
vie de jeune retraité dans son domaine
de 700 acres situé en bordure du
saguenay il a construit sa maison son
atelier son imposante galerie et
d'autres dépendances
il a manifestement réussi son pari de
vivre de sa peinture
pour moi ça va être un grand qui va
dépenser probablement ce qu'on voit
actuellement le dernier richard ou
d'autres peintres ontarien important et
d'open québécois importance gars d'ici
deux ans 70 avec sa femme claire hélène
hovington l'ancien député provincial de
matane qui est aussi son agente
sa conseillère il continue de pratiquer
ces activités de chasse et de pêche
le domaine est maintenant à vendre
ils veulent ralentir un peu mais rené
gagnon ne pense pas une seconde à ça a
été de peindre
pourquoi battre chez mappy